i got a really interesting email from a
viewer over the weekend who sent me
a link to a george packer article in the
atlantic and the article is called we
are living
in a failed state and what this viewer
wants me to consider
which i'm going to do today is instead
of analyzing
the micro failures of trump on
coronavirus so
instead of talking about not enough
testing trump didn't take it seriously
the orwellian press briefings all of
that stuff that would be like a micro
analysis of the failure
from this particular administration on
coronavirus the viewer suggested that i
zoom out and consider whether the
mishandling of coronavirus by trump is
actually a sign of a much broader issue
which is the united states being a
failed state
and we just didn't notice until we had a
real
crisis like coronavirus as george packer
says
in the atlantic the coronavirus didn't
break
america it revealed what was already
broken so i want to think about this
and and really examine whether there may
be something to it now
if we come out with the answer that the
u.s is a failed state it does not
absolve donald trump of responsibility
uh but it would be a different analysis
for us to do so let's start with what is
a failed state what does that mean a
state that has failed
typically to find a failed state is a
political body
that has disintegrated to a point where
basic
conditions and responsibilities of a
sovereign government
no longer function properly the other
side of it is a state can also
fail if the government loses legitimacy
even if it is performing some of those
functions properly
you might remember last week in my
segment donald trump has turned me into
a prepper i pointed out that i've been
doing more
prepping as the term is because of the
realization
i came to that people truly are
ignorant enough in this country to elect
someone like donald trump where
you cannot trust that government
officials will be competent enough
ethical enough empathetic enough
to handle just even the basics during a
situation like this global pandemic
we're dealing with
that would be part of a failed state it
is a characteristic of a failed state
now let's think of some examples usually
when we think of examples of failed
states
from our admittedly western point of
view
we think of places like liberia and
eritrea in africa where you see
combinations of
no infrastructure i mean you know some
there's no clean water no sewage systems
in some cases
to complete dictatorial rule both can be
elements of failed states
we might think of north korea to go to a
different part of the world certainly i
i think that one
makes sense to a lot of people syria is
a very different situation than
liberia north korea and eritrea but
syria is often considered a failed state
although maybe you would see some
revolutionary leftists who disagree iraq
often is considered a failed state
although we can't ignore that
we the united states through foreign
policy
through the first and second world gulf
wars
we've played a big role in getting iraq
to its current state if we determine
it's failed we certainly bear some
responsibility for that
totally different example zimbabwe
zimbabwe over the last couple of decades
is often called a failed state somalia
others
okay so if we apply
the same exact standard that we might
look at in
eritrea or north korea to the u.s the
u.s is not a failed state by that
standard but what i suggest we do is
let's step back a little bit from our
sort of western centric point of view
can we argue that coronavirus has
exposed
the failings of the united states here
are the elements that george packer
points to
which again he says these aren't new
under donald trump
but they have been exposed by
coronavirus not created by coronavirus
exposed by it
i'll include some of george packers
examples from the article which you
should read
and some of mine as well okay a corrupt
political class
we knew about cronyism nepotism
oligopoly etc in the united states
before coronavirus
but coronavirus has really exposed it in
an acute way
total cronyism complete nepotism the
jared kushner fiasco
oligopoly and the handing of these very
lucrative contracts uh to companies that
trump likes that trump has determined
these are the people that are going to
get these contracts
we have it but it's dressed up with some
of the window dressings of democratic
neoliberalism but
we have a corrupt political class here
in the united states
and certainly coronavirus has exposed it
one to two months of distraction from
dealing with the virus with everything
from
lies bragging scapegoating everyone from
china to democrats
that is an element of a failed state
when blown up to a greater degree we've
seen the conspiracy theories and the
promotion
of miracle cures you often see that in
these despotic
countries that are often by western
standards considered failed states
we've seen everything from bill gates
vaccine conspiracy theories
to trump personally promoting the
supposed miracle cure of
hydroxychloroquine for weeks after
then no longer mentioning it again until
last night during his town hall he
brought it back which we'll talk about
endless boasting about how many
ventilators and masks and other ppe
they were getting and making and
ordering as we find out thanks to good
reporting
that we were sending ppe to places like
thailand
at the same time that trump officials
were calling thailand saying
hey we need ppe can you send it to us
wait a second
you're sending us ppe it's like a who's
on first skit
we covered that a few weeks ago a degree
of breakdown
we've seen that led to individuals
having to print masks
with their 3d printers and kids sewing
masks
for healthcare workers a president who
has dealt with the virus
in exclusively political terms often
doing an entire press briefing as we've
seen him do
never talking about the health side of
this fiasco
until a reporter forces him to by asking
a question
a degree of cronyism and inequality
where we see during the pandemic nearly
20 percent of the country
has already lost their jobs but the
super rich and some
corporations are making a killing
profiting from the virus we see a
growing divide
in the country where we have a majority
that is mostly concerned
with the virus and wants to do what
doctors say we should do
and public health experts and then on
the other hand you have this small but
very loud minority
that is aggressively protesting to
reopen their clad with guns and
bulletproof vests
many of whom believe the virus is some
kind of hoax or a fake thing
it's not literally a country run by
warlords as are many of the failed
states we talk about but
if we adjust our analysis for a western
democracy as we like to call it you know
the
the gun-toting people who are demanding
states be reopened
that that's uh that's that's that's a
sign of dystopia to put it lightly
so if we go by the standards that we
often apply to other countries
is the u.s a failed state no it's not
not in the same way that our countries
that
lack running water or transportation or
roads that work or functioning utilities
that's not the the
the standard by which we are a failed
state but this is the united states of
america
we don't typically hold ourselves to the
standards of
syria and north korea and eritrea we can
argue about whether we should or
shouldn't but
we don't left and right typically do not
hold the u.s to that standard
and in a sense we've been left to figure
it out
on our own our own being states
individual states and governors
when it comes to the virus so by our
standards george packer is right
the united states federal government has
dramatically failed and what george
packer points out in his
really eloquently in his article and you
really should read it
is that all of this stuff has been the
case for a long time
one of the richest countries in the
world and yet
so many people have no savings and no
health insurance one of the countries
with the best universities and yet
everything from
anti-vaxxerism to all of the other
anti-science nonsense runs rampant
in certain parts of the country and even
inside of government
that is a failure there is no doubt
about it for the average person the
state
has failed and it's just becoming much
more clear
in the context of coronavirus let me
know what you think i'm curious to hear
from you